hi I'm Eric Voss and we have our first
trailer for Marvel's black panther
directed by Ryan Coogler and with
Chadwick Boseman returning this a
character from Captain America Civil War
this trailer is crazy I don't know what
is going on and I kind of love that
everything looks so new and mysterious
but I'm gonna break down all the
miscible details what we know about all
these characters and why they're secret
society looks so much cooler than ours
does okay let's get started tell me
something what do you know about Canada
it's a third world country text sounds
Shepherds cool outfits okay so this
opening section shows us Martin
Freeman's Everett Ross the CIA agent
that we saw in Captain America's Civil
War interrogating this guy ulysses klaw
played by Andy Serkis now we last saw
Klaw in Avengers age of Ultron he was
the black market arms dealer in South
Africa with the stolen vibranium that he
handed over to Ultron before getting his
arm cut off for dissing Ultron in the
worst possible way Tony Stark used to
say that do I look like Iron Man Stark
and now we learn we're clogged got that
vibranium the African kingdom of Wakanda
so what Conda is the home of Black
Panther and the MCU has been teasing
this for a while now as far back as Iron
Man 2 the country was circled on a map
on the background and then the
post-credits State for civil war we
finally got a full glimpse of it and
these misty waterfalls that we see both
in the post-credits scene and in this
trailer looked like they're part of this
same natural barrier like this is how
Wakanda hides itself in the outside
world to prevent outsiders or satellites
or like annoying drones from being able
to peek in and I like how Ross teases us
by saying Wakanda is known for its cool
outfits there's obviously a double
meaning here he's referring both to the
traditional garb worn by the UN
delegates to civil war but he's also
talking about an even cooler outfit the
woven vibranium suit a black panther
arguably the coolest outfit that we've
seen in the MCU and I'll get to that
suit later but for now let's move on
explorers have searched to it
called it El Dorado
thank for it in South America okay here
it's interesting that claw refers to
Wakanda as Eldorado he's referencing the
mythical city of gold sought after by
Spanish explorers in South America it's
a pretty appropriate comparison because
this Hidden African Eldorado contains an
even more valuable metal vibranium so
what kind of acquired its rich unique
supply vibranium from a meteor that
crashed there long in the past it
allowed the country to flourish
technologically way earlier than the
rest of the world and only bury small
amounts of the metal have ever made it
out of Wakanda like the vibranium that
was used to make Captain America shield
now we know this movie takes place
directly after the events of Captain
America Civil War the death of his
father King to Chaka and Vienna resulted
in T'Challa taking up the mantle of
black panther and cannibal Conda but
like any time a king dies there's a
power struggle so other rivals have
returned to try to claim the throne
canta Tala has to fight them off to
prove himself worthy and I think that's
what's happening here
T'Challa is deboarding his royal Talent
fighter and he's shirtless showing off
these tribal tattoos as if walking into
gladiator combat with all of his
wakandan fans cheering him on he's also
holding a shield here now maybe I'm
crazy but this could be Captain
America's shield remember at the end of
Civil War capped it behind that that
Siberian Hydra base after his fight with
Iron Man so maybe black panther came
across the shield and was like you know
I've been calling the crap out of this
saying it's got to be vibranium which
means it was metal stolen from my
freaking homeland that's it I'm taking
it back damn it or maybe black panther
just picked it up to hold on to for calf
and maybe that Civil War post-credits
scene was cap coming back to pick it up
or maybe it's a different shield anyway
there's this quick shot of Forest
Whitaker's character Zuri who I'll talk
about in a bit but before I move on I
love the look of this shot with these
majestic cliffside waterfalls and
colorful tribal costumes the
cinematographer on this film was Rachel
Morrison who recently shot the movie
dope that movie was super colorful
Morstan is just so great at using
vibrant color palettes to make every
image pop okay let's move on
I'm the only one you seen it and made it
out alive
[Music]
okay so here Black Panther ambushes this
group of rebel soldiers or poachers or
smugglers or just people who stupidly
crossed into that what kind of border
anyway I love how this shot shows them
stealthily perched on a branch like
Black Panthers aren't known to do in the
wild I also like how the dog is barking
up in them because yeah dogs are known
to bark at cats and trees in the wild we
also get to see his suit and fighting
skills in action now the vibranium suit
is bulletproof and he has increased
strength now in the comics that strength
comes from T'Challa eating a special
herb from soil with trace minerals of
vibranium is guys like all metal now
check out these soldiers uniforms and
trucks and radios they seem a little old
right like maybe 80s or early 90s now I
guess these soldiers might just have
older gear but I'm predicting that this
is all part of a flashback like maybe
this isn't T'Challa black panther but
his father too Chaka as a younger man
now later in this trailer we're gonna
see a slightly different black panther
suit which could just be an upgrade or a
redesign or we're seeing two different
suits because we're seeing two different
generations of black panthers let's move
on so here two Chawla is observing claws
interrogation with a ploy a played by
Danai gurira
aka Michonne from The Walking Dead she's
a bodyguard from the Dora Milazzo that's
the king of Wakanda is all-female Royal
Guard might remember one of these
bodyguards threatening Black Widow
during Civil War are you we be moved and
it looks like Grier Oh we'll get a
chance to show off some of her Walking
Dead fighting skills later in the
trailer now how is Klaw able to see
through the one-way mirror like sure
maybe he's just insane but I'm thinking
this could be connected to his origin in
the comics so originally claw was the
one who kills - Chaka and he
loses his hand shortly afterwards went
to China attacks them trying to avenge
his father's death and then later claw
adds to his stump a prosthetic sonic gun
that allows him to create objects using
only sound
he also transforms himself into like an
immortal beam that's made of sound so
maybe the movie version of claw has a
similar power that's related to sound
allowing him to hear using super hearing
or using sound waves to echolocate or
maybe like sense vibrations that enable
him to kind of see through this mirror
wall and before I move on look in the
background here and I could be wrong but
that kind of looks like Steve Rogers
Captain America on the TV monitor he's
wearing similar clothes to when he was a
fugitive in civil war and we know from
that post-credit scene that cap was
recently in Wakanda so I'm curious do
you think that we're gonna see Captain
America show up in this movie and if so
do you think any other MCU characters
might show up too like which ones do you
want to see let me know in the comments
but for now let's move on
[Music]
and okay this section gives us this
gorgeous wide shot of wakanda which is a
massive futuristic metropolis even with
its own expansive transportation grid
the whole look and design of this city
seems to be inspired by Tana he coats
recent run of the Black Panther comics
but really this looks like something out
of like the guardians of the galaxy or
the Thor movies so even though Black
Panther is set on earth in this
dimension it's still gonna have that
eye-popping comic-book feel that these
recent Marvel movies have had by the way
you could check out the breakdowns that
I've done of these other cosmic colorful
visuals and guardians of the galaxy vol
2 and in the Thor Ragnarok trailer ok so
next is this shot of Zuri played by
Forest Whitaker he's a spiritual elder
in this kingdom and a friend to Joe taka
and director Ryan Coogler describes him
as an obi-wan Kenobi figure personally
I've always seen him as more of a saga
or a figure but whatever then we see
this guy putting on a tribal mask as the
brakes claw out of the holding cell now
we get a better look at him later but
this is no Jude akka better known as
Erik Hill Munger played by Michael B
Jordan now his family was exiled from
Wakanda when he was a boy for helping
klog get into the kingdom so he went to
America and took on the name kill monger
and became this super fit super educated
badass just waiting to get his revenge
on T'Challa in the mask that he wears
here is similar to the tribal mask that
he wears in the comics and I think he'll
monger challenging to shala or claim to
the throne will be one of the main
obstacles for this movie and it looks
like he and claw will be working
together in trying to destabilize two
challahs Authority in Wakanda then we
meet another character Lupita Nyong'o as
Nakia she's another warrior in the Dora
Malaysia now in the comics she's a love
interest to T'Challa
and she's later corrupted and given
powers by kill monger who gives her the
name malice we'll see things go this way
in the movie but in this shot Nakia is
walking through this casino which i
think is part of the sequence that takes
place in South Korea apparently there's
a major chase sequence that was shot in
Busan and we'll see a few shots from
that later in the trailer and throughout
this section we hear this warning from
T'Challa father to Chaka
the wound is changing
to be the contractor and so again I feel
like there's probably some kind of
flashback sequence in this movie elastic
shaka is speaking to his son from beyond
the grave like Mufasa really these kind
of sound like words of wisdom that to
Chaka is saying to T'Challa when he was
a boy and this all hints to a major
theme in this movie whether or not
Wakanda and Black Panther can remain
isolationist like at some point they're
gonna be conquered or conquerors either
the hunted or the hunters now something
interesting is happening in this shot to
chala approaching his fellow wakandans
at first I thought he's approaching a
rival kind of like come on what else you
got but notice how his facial expression
changes it starts with a subtle smile of
familiarity and then it drops to get
more serious
maybe T'Challa is greeting his friends
and family but then he realized that
something is wrong now based on the
flames in the foreground of this shot
this seems like it could be taking place
in the aftermath of some kind of battle
or attack so I don't know I'm kind of
feeling that maybe - Charla is like
coming home to find someone he loves his
dine or maybe he's walking up about to
invite everyone out for drinks and then
he realizes that they were all planning
on hanging out without him it happens to
the best of us in each other anyway let
me know what you think is going on in
the scene in the comments but before we
move on we get these quick shots of Klaw
in a museum
apparently in disguise now check out
that patch that crest is for the
Northwest
ambulance service meaning this is
probably somewhere in the UK
maybe the British Museum in London now
in the background there are these
various African artifacts like masks and
head pieces maybe Klaw is hoping that
one of these will contain traces of
vibranium or some other clue to the
location of Wakanda and it's his failed
heist here that lands him in Ross's
custody okay let's move on
our is good man
in his heart for a good lab to be a
so here we see two challahs speaking at
another UN General Assembly meeting and
the music that plays here is legend has
it by hip-hop duo run the jewels the
lyrics of step into the spotlight is
another example of the theme that I
talked about earlier that in order to
save the kingdom to chalo will have to
leave obscurity and literally step up
into the spotlight suppose either of us
is used to the spotlight well it's not
always so flattering now it seems like
in this trailer they're going for a mix
of African tribal music and Western
hip-hop and I kind of like it not
everyone is crazy about it but I'm
curious to see what kind of soundtrack
that Ryan Coogler ends up using in this
movie I really love the mix of music
that he used for creed but let me know
what you think about this music in the
comments next we get a shot of kill
monger again this time is courted by
Daniel Kaluga and advisor to Sharla now
you may know kahlúa from the amazing
movie that came out this year get out
and based on kill mongers pose here it
looks like his hands could be bound like
this could be a flashback to when he was
exiled or this is after he helps claw
and now he has to face his punishment
and this actor here is Isaac to Punk
Olay he has a lip plate which is a form
of body modification practiced in
Ethiopia now in some tribes the size of
the disk connotes social or economic
importance so I'm guessing that this guy
is the leader of his particular tribe it
looks like there's gonna be some
infighting between the tribes of Wakanda
the family's character can be seen in
the background of where kill monger and
de chala fight in the pools so I'm
thinking in the absence of a king all
the tribal elders meet and decide that
combat is the only way they're gonna be
able to decide who the new king will be
but it looks like the chawla has another
rival new Baku also known as man ape
he's played by Winston do and in the
comics he gets his name by eating the
flesh of the white gorilla and bathing
in its blood which gives him powers and
here my Baku is the ruler of the
mountain tribe he and his people live in
a snowy mountain region of Wakanda we
also meet a few other members of two
challahs family here his stepmother
Queen R Amanda played by Angela Bassett
and notice how Ross is with her in this
shot so maybe he's there to help broker
a deal between the different tribes we
also see Leticia Wright playing two
challahs sister Cherie
she's holding his awesome vibranium
Panther head hand
now Wright has described her character
as having the intelligence of Tony Stark
so she's kind of like the Q from James
Bond to T'Challa like she uses vibranium
to design that's clever weaponry and
suit modifications we also see a quick
shot of this South Korea chase sequence
but I'll talk more about it after we
look at this final section
okay so black panther suit is obviously
upgraded here when he smashes into the
hood of this SUV it releases a shockwave
which isn't something that happened in
civil war when he did that by the way
the bridge that he's on here is the
gwangan de geo bridge in Busan South
Korea and lights up with these
interesting purple colors at nighttime
but let's take a closer look at this
suit this is definitely different from
the one that we saw earlier in the
trailer and in civil war like the suit
is sleeker and more form-fitting and the
mask is different and has fewer
vibranium stripes and the eye holes are
larger now lately in superhero movies
customers and visual effects people have
been taking steps to try to make masked
heroes eyes more expressive like in
Deadpool and in civil war with
spider-man
they animated the eyes so that the
character has more personality when he's
giving his lines but here Black Panthers
eyes seem pretty rigid so I'm curious to
see how they get around that in this
movie one way is they could show him
more often with his mask off like they
too would Captain America or they could
try something similar to what they do at
Iron Man cutting to a close-up of his
inner helmet display actually in the
comics some more advanced versions of
black panther suit do have an inner cpu
similar to Iron Man's so maybe that's
part of this redesign of his new suit
like that's a new feature that Sheree
put in just to nag to Chawla as he's you
know flipping over SUVs on bridges in
South Korea but let me know your
thoughts about Black Panthers mask like
do you want them to be more expressive
with either an inner close-up like Iron
Man's or no mask at all or are you cool
with these rigid non expressive eyes
like I'll admit it does make it look way
more intimidating and make sure to weigh
in on those other things that I asked
about too like any other MCU cameos
you'd like to see and thoughts on the
music now this movie is scheduled to
release on February 16 2018 and I am so
pumped for this movie I feel like I did
when I saw that first teaser of Doctor
Strange like this movie looks so
different and new but still very Marvel
and fun and you can subscribe to new
rockstars to see all the other videos
where we break down all these Marvel
properties and as we wait for February
let's keep this conversation going like
this video and share it if you could
tweet about it that would be awesome and
we would love it if you could include a
link to this video and if want to be a
bigger part of what we do here at new
rock stars you can contribute to us on
patreon big thanks to all of our current
donors
ashle Matthew solve us so tweet at me
with all of your thoughts and reactions
to this amazing Black Panther trailer at
da boss you can also follow new rock
stars on twitter at new rock starts for
updates on our videos alright thanks for
watching bye